what criteria do you meet before
committing to a purchase well see my
pithy answer is really lame but I
thought it was funny enough so it's like
the remember the Johnnie Cochran line it
doesn't fit you must acquit yes I mean I
had to work on this one for a while it's
so lame like this is my lameness minimal
Maxim talk about good quality versus
quantity well it's just like it's lame
because it's cheesy yeah it is so if it
doesn't fit you must deep-six
wrong yeah so let's just talk about this
no it's good some questions that I asked
myself the idea behind it I totally get
him and it's great so if I were to
rephrase Susan's question what criteria
do you meet before committing to
approaches there what questions do you
ask before making a purchase so number
one can I afford it so can I afford its
actual cost right the watering of the
plants yeah okay can I afford the actual
monetary costs do I have the money I
think if I have to go into debt for it I
can't afford it if I don't have the
space for it I can't afford it if I have
to buy something extra for this thing I
probably can't afford it right so what
is the actual cost of the thing and can
I afford that actual cost number two
will it add value to my life what I mean
by that does it serve a purpose or does
it bring me joy or ideally both right
you know the the the plants are a good
example they they bring joy they serve
as a decoration they don't have an
actual function but the purpose is they
look good now indoor plants they
actually help filter the air as well so
it does serve an additional purpose
there so does it add value to my life
doesn't serve a purpose does it bring me
joy number three what are the
alternatives to this thing sometimes I
think we don't ask this question enough
like well yes I can afford the thing I
got the money in my checking account
right and then yeah I think this thing
will serve a perv I another pair of
pants that would serve a purpose right
but then what's the alternative what can
I do with that extra hundred dollars
what's the alternative what else can I
do with this money what's your what's
your opportunity cost yeah exactly yeah
economic economic turn term is
opportunity cost so so what else can I
do with this money right and then the
fourth thing that I asked myself I'm if
I'm absolutely certain so the exercise
bike that we recently purchased would
fall
this oh and I'm writing something about
this coming up so can I wait 30 hours if
it's more than $30 or 30 days if it's
greater than $100 I know I wrote down
$20 but it's actually 30 because it's
the 30 30 rule hmm this new rule that
I'm working on here
so can I wait 30s is basic is a day or
more like can at least waited a 30 hours
if it's more than $30 can I wait a day
now there'll be some cases where I can't
wait a day right because I really need
this widget or whatever yeah it costs 35
bucks now if it's more than $100 can I
wait at least 30 days on it again the
exercise bike was it was a great example
because certainly more than a hundred
dollars and we waited well over 30 days
deliberating over this decision in the
venture we decided to pull the trigger
and and and and get it but it was out
and I can feel better about that
purchase because I know that it's not a
it wasn't an impulse buy absolutely it
was absolutely deliberate dude I feel
that way about my coffee grinder like I
have had a manual grinder and for the
last four years yeah and a couple months
ago I just I was reading this thing
where basically an electric grinder is
better than a hand grinder and I just
didn't realize that and I really like
having and making the best cup of coffee
I can in the morning right get a lot of
joy out of it so I finally went out and
I got a grinder the reason why I had
avoided this purchase for so long cuz
like a good electric grinders over a
hundred bucks so I went spent like 120
hundred 30 bucks on this grinder dude it
is I just got the grinder app and I mean
it does have the difference but like you
find you find some muscular man to grind
your coffee for you yeah is that a
euphemism you're gonna love it
dude I cannot tell you the amount of
difference like I have I felt like I was
like [ __ ] man like I have been like
depriving myself of this not just a
convenience but it does it does produce
a better grind which produces a better
cup of coffee do you know the brand
maybe we can talk about that value I
don't but I can certainly talk about
next week talk about next week sure
sounds good man I will yes we'll put a
pin in that all right here's my short
answer for you Susan a few things to
consider before making a purchase budget
occupied space and hit
costs I think the LAT the the last one
there hidden costs that's something that
I used to forsake a lot like I'd buy a
really nice pair of like Allen Edmonds
shoes and then you're still made in
America somehow yes and they're they're
great it's a great shoe company don't
get me wrong yeah um but you know
polishing them up as often as I had to
polish them up didn't really consider
that when I bought that pair of shoes
right there are just certain hidden
costs that that if we if we buy an
impulse we will miss those hidden costs
and we'll regret it later
you